the Joe Rogan experience honestly if
it's one um well no even during my shows
like covering weigh-ins weigh-ins I'll
wear a t-shirt
that's one thing ufc's been doing it's
bolt making cool t-shirts for each
Reebok I make a cool t-shirt for each
place you go to you know have you been
wearing those sometimes I don't use more
the plastic yeah you rock on it one
usually but I wore the Boston one Boston
they made a dope one who's green with
like a bumblebee looks like a bumblebee
with gloves on at the UFC's like
backstage who is like the head honcho
walking around is there someone above
Dana that's walking around and hanging
out backstage or statement well Dana is
always run in the show for sure is there
like oh [ __ ] that's the golden schnitz
right Nowitzki is the guy everyone's
kind of like well no no he means like
running the show just walking around
hanging out no there's nobody president
man and Ari is so bloody owned that
[ __ ] - oh no no but when he comes there
it's very brief and he comes for the
fights or he comes to the weigh-ins he
goes you know [ __ ] busy that dude
must be he's in and out you just don't
know there you'll see suicide - yeah not
even it's a big company it's a it's a
business they put together with a bunch
of celebrities bought into it and you
know it's a real big deal well yes
probably a lot of people bought into it
I would have to look at and that's like
part owner of the UFC well don't ask
questions honestly I really don't ask a
lot of good like I was gonna care I've
been working there forever
I asked almost no questions this is what
I asked what are you gonna do with this
guy what are you doing that and you
watch oh and you like you can't tell
anybody this this world my god [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] that's the questions I asked for
Dana I never asked questions about
business or who bought this or I don't
have enough room in my brain to give a
[ __ ] about other people's business I
have zero interest in the people's
business I mean literally zero
especially with the UFC I don't give a
[ __ ] I just want to know who's fighting
who's fighting who what are you gonna do
I'm not like how
this guy gonna make what percentages he
own and who's he what's he doing and how
is he gonna make his money back and what
kind of financial return on his
investment you're gonna get I don't give
a [ __ ] about see but when they say those
celebrities are owners it's just like a
business trip they don't they might not
be into the officious as far as money
like well that's my people are into
getting famous people to invest in [ __ ]
too it's a fun thing LL Cool J is that
LL Cool J me Kimmel hmm there you go
there's Mike Beltran he owns it too they
don't have any say Mike belt round get
the best [ __ ] mustache in the game I
have been owns a piece of pie how about
your about Nick Newell Anthony Kiedis
there we go
caliber Levine owns a piece the UFC damn
damn damn so a lot of people bought in
oh it's on the beam I thought what the
[ __ ] is he doing in the fight game so
what they do is they you know they
probably everybody chips in a little bit
man that's a stretch Jim stock they skim
stock so pretty sure I'm sure they
didn't chip in I don't think they chip
well I think it was Don Moore would they
give him stock for cuz they own the
business right they're not then I can
cash from those guys I don't think well
what then why would they do that
while they give them a piece of the
business for no reason hmm they'd have
to give him money I don't know see this
is why I don't do this I don't like this
is why I don't doing this I don't like
wondering who's paying what or how
they're doing do you want to hear about
it now we like it we like
[Applause]